[Musique]
et ce soir un jour avec les finalistes
du concours d'éloquence des lycéens très
jeunes garçons et filles venus de toute
l'île se sont retrouvés cette semaine
sur la scène du théâtre de saint gilles
pour la finale du concours régional
d'éloquence très jeunes invités à
discourir sur le thème bien d'actualité
de l'égalité entre hommes et femmes une
belle aventure que jean marc collienne
et laurent figues ont suivi avec ludovic
un lycéen dionisi mercredi soir 19h
théâtre de saint gilles
ludovic babef ouvre le bal du concours
régional d'éloquence pas facile d'être
le produit
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je suis là
aujourd'hui pour aborder avec vous un
deuil qui me tient à coeur
l'égalité car aujourd'hui nous vivons
dans un monde qui souffre d'un mal ce
discours il l'a répété des centaines de
fois
souvent devant toute sa famille comme ce
matin encore que à l'heure du petit
déjeuner avant de prendre la route pour
ça j'ai pas abouti l'inégalité homme
femme voulait après allez l'égalité
hommes femmes
commencez par libération parce qu'il n'y
avait pas foule
la maison eh ben on est trois garçons
déjà maté pas encore beaucoup de choses
et bien nos parents nous a un peu mes
parents m'ont appris à l adsl passe le
balai doux voilà on peut dire que c'est
pas quelque chose se réserver que pour
les filles ludovic a toujours été un bon
élève et il s'est toujours impliqué dans
la vie scolaire
il a même été vice président du conseil
départemental des jeunes mais a toujours
été sérieux comme ça le 2d qui est lourd
beaucoup lire et moi maman je crois que
ludovic où les trous de mise mais cela
m'a beaucoup coûté et migros temps parce
que josé mari comme ça même va avancer
et peut-être va redonner valley jouer
ici mais il laissera pas noir je vous
dirais ou les ambitieux je pense que la
poussette giteau ne connais pas ses
sources l'ambition là et l'a surpris à
moi et depuis le conseil général c'est
la vraie bague aux azzurri vettel est
l'homme politique vous faire appeler et
pourquoi pas commencer vers la mairie de
saint-louis futur grâce à vue qu'espéré
[Musique]
en attendant il est temps pour ludovic
de rejoindre les autres candidats du
concours d'éloquence
bonjour ma faveur il 113 venus des
quatre coins de l ensemble ce matin il
foule pour la première fois les planches
du théâtre de saint gilles avec pour les
accompagner le comédien francis convoqué
à l'aide
avec ce que vous avez devant vous n'en
ayez pas peur c'est ce soir en face de
vous il y aura que des gens qui vont
être bienveillant des besoins qui vont
être là pour vous supporter pour vous
épauler pour vous mettre en l'air par
contre si je vais taire les gens comme
ça ce matin
les finalistes vont d'abord travaillé
avec jacqueline war ou une des
chanteuses du groupe les voies d et la
première chose pour émettre un son est
ce que vous savez ce que c'est aussi la
respiration fij
voilà mais parce que cela hypothèque la
suite se déroule à l'ombre du théâtre ça
c'est la respiration qu'on devrait avoir
d'habitude
[Musique]
oh
et ce soir il faudra bien respirer mais
également donné de la voix
à
ok on va détendre un petit peu tout ça
parce que jacqueline a rapidement perçu
le point faible de ludo son côté un peu
trop sage position il ne reste
maintenant plus qu'une heure avant la
représentation
on s'est dit on se maquille et on répète
une dernière fois son taxe carbone d'ici
là aujourd'hui pour aborder avec vous un
thème qui me tient à coeur
l'égalité hommes femmes oui on met un
temps là
d'accord un temps très très long mais
j'ai deux trois secondes
oui oui vous m'avez bien entendu tuân à
cobham vous allez bien entre ce que j'ai
dit il a du coup ça te permet de pouvoir
entrer plus facilement dans cette
émotion de temps je te laisse un petit
temps
d'accord les griffes
oui
vous avez bien entendu l'égalité est sur
ce thème de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes
les 13 finalistes vont chacun exprimé
leurs convictions leurs espoirs leurs
indications
vous prétendez que les femmes devraient
acquérir un salaire inférieur à celui
des hommes
par quel souvent intelligente mais un
loup du gast on est au 21ème la loi sur
la parité ça vous dit quelque chose
car la farm aujourd'hui je subis des
phrases telles que et été bonne 134
femmes sont mortes l'an dernier sous les
coups des conjoints violents comme vous
c'est est une femme
vidéo fouillé ce beau monde et apple ils
m'aiment
il m'a tuer
moi en tout cas demain j'espérais qu'il
droit
non je ne serai pas votre femme de
ménage
je sais rien fait qui dirigera le monde
à vous maintenant depuis agir mais cet
espoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]